>> Tucker: AMERICANS MOST
POWERFUL TECH COMPANIES KNOW
MORE ABOUT YOU THAN YOUR PARENTS
DO.
THEY SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
OTHERS.
TODAY, FACEBOOK ADMITTED IT GAVE
DATA ON 87 MILLION PEOPLE TO
CAMBRIDGE TO CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICAL.
NO BIG DEAL.
THEY SUPPRESS FREE SPEECH.
THEY DELIBERATELY GET CHILDREN
HOOKED ON THEM.
THEY BRAG ABOUT HOW PEOPLE BY
THEMSELVES WITH AN MORTALITY
DURING THE END.
WHAT DEFENSE CAN BE MADE OF THE
TAX INDUSTRY WHICH INCREASINGLY
OCCUPIES A CENTRAL PLACE IN OUR
LIVES?
STEVE LARKIN AS PRESIDENT OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY COUNCIL.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THESE COMPANIES ARE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THEY'RE AMAZING.
FACEBOOK IS AN AMAZING PRODUCT
AND I WOULD NEVER DENY THAT.
THEY'RE AN AMERICAN COMPANY AND
I'M PROUD OF THAT.
THERE'S A MASSIVE DOWNSIDE THAT
HAS BEEN SUPPRESSED.
I CAN NAME A LOT.
HERE'S JUST ONE.
WE'VE SEEN A MASSIVE SPIKE AND
SUICIDE RATES ESPECIALLY IN
KIDS.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY'RE DRIVEN BY
FACEBOOK.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT, AND
ADDICTIVE PRODUCT THAT HURT
PEOPLE FROM CIGARETTES?
>> THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
SMOKING NICOTINE IS ADDICTIVE
AND IT'S BAD FOR YOUR HEALTH.
I DON'T THINK THAT EVIDENCE
EXISTS FOR FACEBOOK OR OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT BEING SAID, MOST OF THE
COMPANIES THAT WE REPRESENT
UNDERSTAND THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO SOCIETY AND ARE MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE EVALUATING WHAT'S
GOING ON.
>> Tucker: HERE'S SEAN PARKER
AND HOW HE DESCRIBED HIS
COMPANY.
IT'S EXPLOITING A VULNERABILITY
AND HUMAN PSYCHOLOGY.
IT LITERALLY CHANGES YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OTHERS AND
INTERFERES WITH PRODUCTIVITY.
GOD KNOWS WHAT IT'S DOING TO OUR
CHILDREN'S BRAIN.
THE MORE PEOPLE WHO USE
FACEBOOK, THE LESS HEALTHY THEY
ARE AND THEIR LESS SATISFIED
WITH THEIR LIVES.
WE KNOW IT HURTS PEOPLE UNLESS
SCIENCE IS INVALID AND WE KNOW
IT'S DESIGNED TO BE ADDICTIVE.
HOW IS THAT ALLOWED?
>> I DON'T THINK WE KNOW IT'S
DESIGNED TO BE ADDICTIVE.
AND OF THE PEOPLE WHO FOUNDED
THOSE COMPANIES DIDN'T CREATE
THEM WITH ADDICTION OR DOING
HARM IN MIND.
THEY GREETED THEM TO DO
SOMETHING PRETTY PHENOMENAL, AS
YOU NOTED WHICH IS TO DEEPEN
SOCIAL CONNECTIONS.
>> Tucker: HOW DOES THAT
HAPPEN?
WE LOOKED PRETTY CLOSELY.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE STUDY THAT
HAS SHOWN THAT THE MORE YOU USE
SOCIAL MEDIA, THE MORE CONNECTED
YOU ARE TO PEOPLE.
YOU'RE MORE ISOLATED.
I HAVE 2015 FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF MISSOURI, 2016, ALL THESE
SHOW THAT SOCIAL MEDIA AND
INCREASES LIFE SATISFACTION
BECAUSE THEY ALIENATE PEOPLE
FROM EACH OTHER.
>> IN MY VIEW, THERE IS NO
REASON TO ADMIT SOMETHING THAT'S
BEING STUDIED.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
NEUROLOGICAL IMPLICATIONS AND A
DEEP DESIRE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS ARE.
IF THERE IS A PROBLEM, DO SOME
THING ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: HOW MUCH MONEY IS
FACEBOOK SPENDING?
>> I THINK THE COMPANIES TO TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY.
IT'S NOT TO SUGGEST THEY'RE NOT
STUDYING IT.
IN ALL THE DISCUSSIONS TODAY,
MOST OF THE RESPONSE FROM THE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN NOT
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED, BUT LET'S
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
THE IMPLICATIONS ARE.
>> Tucker: WE ARE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THIS.
THERE'S BEEN EVIDENCE FOR A
WHILE THAT MIGHT BE HARMFUL.
WHY HAVE THEY NOT TAKEN A LEAD?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE.
>> WRONG.
>> Tucker: ANY TIME YOU WANT
TO COME BACK, IF THERE IS
COUNTERVAILING EVIDENCE, I WANT
TO SEE IT.